il y a des raisons de sortir de cette de
résignation de cette sinistrose
oui il ya le chômage alors bien sûr il
est beaucoup trop oui il ya une
inversion de la courbe du chômage dans
l'année 2016 et françois hollande est en
train de relever le défi et de la
bataille de l'emploi créé dessus on peut
applaudir françois fille françois fillon
nom françois hollande
on applaudira françois fillon parce que
françois villon c'est celui qui nous
permettra de retrouver la croissance
oui un milliard d'euros je vous dirais
que ça nous a coûté à nous les
contribuables parce que la réalité c'est
françois hollande à acheter la baisse du
chômage américains nar estime que cette
baisse du chômage a été obtenue en plus
artificiellement
beaucoup de chômeurs serait envoyé en
stage afin d'être sortis des
statistiques par françois mitterrand
l'ancien président aurait aujourd'hui
100 ans
un hommage lui a été rendu fou la
pyramide du louvre par françois
mitterrand un opposant qui n'a jamais
cédé au moindre découragement même quand
les épreuves semblait l'avoir écarté à
tout jamais de la vie politique
le risque c'est que nous soyons sap et
de la présidentielle on a un problème
d'incarnation cinq ans et un de ses amis
proches lui dit c'est dangereux d'y
aller il ne faut pas se faire humilier
est ce que vous vous lui donnez un nom
sur la scène un homme françois
mitterrand qui n'a cessé de rassembler
rassembler la gauche pour ensuite unir
le pays
car quand vous entendez le patron du ps
jean-christophe cambadélis il était à
votre place il ya deux jours dira si
c'est pas hollande ça pourrait être
valls mais qu'en dites vous manuel valls
mais tout cela je longtemps oui et donc
emmanuel macron toujours pas candidat
dit son attachement à la fonction
présidentielle
pas forcément au chef de l'état il doit
tenir compte de la situation
il doit donner un sens à ce que pourrait
être sa candidature et un nouveau
quinquennat
cette décision lui appartient de
fonctions qu'on occupe à un moment donné
elle nous dit
et donc moi mon souhait à tous égards
c'est qu'on affaiblisse pas la fonction
présidentielle pris à cette phrase qui
me consorts souvent de mitterrand je
serai le dernier grand président après
moi il y'aura t des comptables y avait
raison écoutez il l'a dit dans
l'hypothèse où alain juppé candidat les
républicains françois hollande n'arrive
que cinquième derrière le possible
candidat emmanuel matheron et derrière
jean-luc mélenchon il est malade on est
là des bons elle est un petit tout petit
peu de votre réserve il a raison non
mais il l'a dit sur les copies wii faut
du sang neuf
et puis en même temps vos faire barrage
à nicolas sarkozy donc on va voter pour
alain juppé est un vote par défaut et je
dis à tous ces électeurs un vote par
défaut
ça donnera la même déception que
françois hollande parce que justement
elle trouvait trop froid trop ennuyeux
mais vous dis justement c'est l'époque
qui a changé parce qu'on a envie de
s'ennuyer avec alain juppé vraie
déclaration d'amour